[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour cet épisode cette fois-ci
dédié à l'archéologie d'une zone précise
la vallée de l'indus avant de plonger
dans les vestiges de cette civilisation
je tenais à vous remercier du fond du
coeur pour tous vos commentaires sous la
vidéo des penseurs du 20e siècle je
pense sincèrement refaire ce type de
format qui vous plaît tant et cette
vidéo est là dans le petit alors si j'ai
pas été très présente pour vous répondre
bah c'est que j'étais en reportage à
l'étranger pour un projet absolument fou
en arabie saoudite je vous en reparle
très vite et d'ici là je vous invite à
activer la cloche à me suivre sur
instagram pour être tenu au courant de
la sortie de cette vidéo qui arrive très
prochainement promis je fumais pas
poireauter six mois
il a des civilisations qui passe
inaperçu pourtant celle dont on va
parler aujourd'hui à dominer un
territoire d'un million de kilomètres
carrés pendant 700 en posséder sa propre
écriture des villes de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'habitants et
commercer avec tout le moyen-orient
cette civilisation ceara pas du nom du
premier grands sites identifiés mais on
l'appelle aussi la civilisation de
l'indus du nom du fleuve au bord duquel
elle s'est épanouie à rapa nous est donc
pratiquement inconnu rien à voir avec
les dizaines de livres de vulgarisation
qui sortent tous les ans sur l'egypte la
grèce ou même la mésopotamie et il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela déjà parce que
le pakistan où se trouve la majorité des
sites n'est pas un pays spécialement
touristique du fait d'un contexte
géopolitique assez tendue ensuite parce
que les sites archéologiques fait de
briques crues pour la plupart ne sont
pas aussi majestueux que ceux de
l'egypte pharaonique mais à rapa est
inconnu chez nous aussi et surtout parce
qu'il n'y a pratiquement pas de
bibliographie en français tout au plus
quelques pages dans les ouvrages
généraux sur l'histoire de l'inde on
attend peut-être un volume de la
collection mon ancien sur le sous
continent indien pour avoir quelque
chose de plus complet et accessible vous
savez mon ancien c'est la collection
dont je vous parle très souvent chez
belin j'en ai pas mal ici c'est bientôt
noël donc si vous avez envie de vous
faire plaisir ou de faire plaisir à
quelqu'un c'est un super cadeau à offrir
les sources qui ont servi à préparer cet
épisode proviennent donc en grande
majorité de publications en anglais ce
sont des revues internationales
spécialisées comme le journal of
archaeological science donc pas du tout
vulgariser même si certains articles
sont accessibles gratuitement sur
internet et puis il faut bien avouer que
les articles anglo saxons ont la
fâcheuse tendance d'être assez creux
c'est pas du racisme anti anglais 1
qu'une dire ça c'est le reflet des
conditions de la recherche et là je fais
une petite parenthèse en bas ce qui se
passe c'est que plutôt que de publier
une synthèse complète qui sert à tout le
monde est bien en ce moment on découpe
un article pour le publier dans quatre
revue différentes si vous voulez et
faire plus de ligne sur son cv résultat
dans les infos sont éparpillés et c'est
très difficile d'avoir une bonne vue
d'ensemble quand on n'est pas
spécialiste je vous passe aussi les
publications de 1000 pages qui compile
30 ans de fouilles d'un seul site je
vous le cache pas là on n'a pas eu le
temps
moralité cette vidéo essaye de donner un
aperçu rapide de cette civilisation
malgré toutes ces difficultés
heureusement pour nous il ya un bon
livre de synthèse récents en langue
anglaise celui de jane macintosh
beaucoup utilisé pour ce qui va suivre
commençons par aller voir une carte
parce que je sais pas vous mais le
pakistan ce n'est pas forcément un pays
avec lequel j'étais le plus familière
l'indus est un fleuve qui descend de
l'himalaya au nord est qui va se jeter
dans l'océan indien au sud à vale est
encadrée par les montagnes de l'hindu
kuch et du balouchistan à l'ouest et le
grand désert de thar à l'est c'est donc
un espace assez contraint
géographiquement et les grands sites de
peuplement humain sont logiquement
installé au bord du fleuve et du
littoral les sites de la vallée de
l'indus sont découverts dans les années
1820 mais fouillé sentant plus tard
excaver à grands coups de pioche par des
centaines d'ouvriers au début du 20e
siècle les grandes villes de la vallée
de l'indus ont bien livré quantité
d'objets archéologiques mais toute
information sur la disposition ou leurs
positions dans la stratigraphie est à
jamais perdue c'est la fameuse technique
de bourrins qu'on l'évoqué dans le
précédent épisode 1 je vous laisse aller
voir chapitre leroi gourhan par ailleurs
les villes et en particulier à rapa ont
servi de carrière de briques à toutes
les époques postérieur ce qui a
grandement endommagé les constructions
et rendues souvent impossible de dresser
des plans d'ensemble partant de là les
folies xxème siècle ont toutefois mis au
jour une situation particulièrement
original avec ses plantes ville
orthogonaux orienté parfaitement sur les
points cardinaux son omniprésence
d'évacuation d'eau et de salles de bains
dans les maisons ou encore son extrême
standardisation des mesures dès le
troisième millénaire avant jésus-christ
à rapa a profondément surpris les
archéologues les milliards de bricard
apn qui ont servi à construire les
villes ont toutes des dimensions de 1
par deux par quatre les pois utilisé
pour le commerce sont tous des multiples
d'une unité de base de 0 87 g et toutes
les longueurs sont basées sur une unité
de 17 mm pour moi qu'il est construite
cette ville un joule direct on connaît
quelques très grandes agglomérations qui
s'étendent sur des centaines d'hectares
à rapa mohenjo daro gagnent mairie ou à
la chan ou d'arreau raki gary dole avira
etc
la culture à apn est présente sur plus
de 1000 sites en tout dont une centaine
ont été fouillés mais à eux seuls les
sites de mohenjo daro et à rapa cumul
87% du matériel retrouvé les datations
font aujourd'hui remonter la fondation
de ces villes art 2500 avant notre ère
l'économie de subsistance est basé sur
l'élevage du début avec transhumance une
partie de l'année et l'agriculture
céréalière du blé et de l'orge des
ressources sauvage complète évidemment
le régime alimentaire en particulier le
poisson du fleuve les chants sont
irrigués au moyen de retenues d'eau et
de canalisations alimenté par les pluies
et les rivières le climat permet de
récoltes par an une aviculture divers
rabhi de type méditerranéen avec
céréales lentilles pois chiches raisins
figues dattes pistage et anand et une
culture d'été carif plus tropical qui
comprend le coton le mil et le sorgho la
canne à sucre la mangue les haricots ou
encore le cézanne dont on extrait de
ville cette double culture permet de
réduire les risques les rendements dans
la vallée de l'indus peuvent être très
bon mais sont assez irrégulier la grande
uniformité des objets des techniques et
des constructions constatée dans tous
les sites là les cultures irriguées à
grande échelle tout fait penser à
l'existence d'un état centralisé dans la
vallée de l'indus dans l'antiquité
pourtant malgré cette unité apparente
les traces d'une organisation politique
religieuse manque toujours
on ne connaît pas en effet dans toute la
vallée de l'indus de résidence ou de
palais qui aurait pu jouer le rôle de
centre administratif on ne connaît pas
non plus deux temples public ou en tout
cas la fonction cultuelle des édifices
et pour l'instant passée inaperçue c'est
étonnant car ces deux types de bâtiments
temple et palais sont d'habitude les
plus massifs et les mieux conservées et
pas de tombes princières non plus à se
mettre sous la dent
l'absence de conflits visible pose aussi
question les épais remparts de certaines
villes par exemple 18 mètres d'épaisseur
et 9 mètres de haut à dole avira ne
semble pas avoir subi d'autres assauts
que celui des inondations ces murs
souvent interprétés comme défensif sur
la base de ce qu'on connaît dans les
autres régions du monde était peut-être
de simples digue dans bien des cas on ne
connaît d'ailleurs pas d'armes forget
que des pointes de flèches aussi bien
utilisée pour la chasse pas de pouvoir
pas de religion pas de guerre la vallée
de l'indus commence à ressembler à une
véritable utopie mais bon c'est sans
doute trop beau pour être vrai
l'abondance des salles de bains dans les
maisons fait tout de même penser à des
usages rituel de l'eau et le grand
bassin de moine jo d'arros situé sur un
point haut de la ville pourrait lui
aussi avoir une fonction religieuse les
foyers dans les maisons pourraient aussi
avoir joué un rôle pour des rituels
domestiques et les quelques sculptures
de pierre de moine jodar au bien
qu'incomplète était peut-être des
portraits de souverains la mieux
conservée et généralement interprétée
comme un traître roi sans qu'on ait
d'autres indices à ce sujet beaucoup de
statues est grossière en terre cuite
représentant des femmes ont par ailleurs
été interprétée comme des déesses mères
mais on a déjà expliqué sur cette chaîne
la faiblesse de cette théorie donc il ya
deux vidéos vous pouvez les voir il ya
une conférence que j'avais donnée en
live sur youtube est également une vidéo
assez anciennes sur la chaîne qui expose
les théories d' alain testart sur les
statuts à du néolithique quelques
figures énigmatiques sur des décors de
poterie ou de saugues graves et
pourraient correspondre à des divinités
ou des figures mythologiques mais en
l'absence de texte il est impossible de
les identifier
on a aussi souvent voulu tracer des
correspondances entre les religions
indienne postérieur en y voyant des
positions évoquant le yoga par exemple
et là encore n'y a rien de certain
face à cette absence apparente d'un état
certains archéologues avance l'idée que
la civilisation d'un rappaz n'était pas
centralisé mais plutôt une sorte de
fédération de marchands l'uniformité de
la culture matérielle ne serait donc pas
la conséquence d'une unification
politique mais plutôt de réseaux de
distribution interne très développé
c'est le cas par exemple pour le silex
grille du gisement de rory diffusé dans
toute la vallée les échanges d'un rap
avec l'extérieur sont par ailleurs bien
attestée on a retrouvé les produits
fabriqués dans la vallée de l'indus dans
tout le moyen-orient mais perdre
d'agathe cornaline jasse aux knicks ou
en coquillages typique d'un rappaz ont
été largement identifiés en mésopotamie
ou dans la péninsule arabique en échange
des exportations à rappaz devait
recevoir des produits périssables sans
doute de la laine que les mésopotamiens
produisait en quantité industrielle
l'indus et est donc au coeur d'un
commerce international mais
paradoxalement pas du tout tourner vers
l'inde uniquement vers l'ouest les
routes terrestres vers l'ouest et le
nord traverser le plateau iranien ou des
sites sont connus aux carrefours
stratégiques
cela permettait de contrôler la
production de certains matériaux comme
le bois des montagnes himalayennes où
les ressources du sous-sol métaux et
pierres semi précieuses comme la
turquoise ou le lapis lazuli l'un des
éléments les plus probants dans cette
organisation commerciale à grande
échelle sont les sauts inscrits de forme
carrée portant un dessin d'animal et
quelques caractères d'écriture ils sont
les artefacts les plus iconiques de la
civilisation européenne ils sont faits
la plupart du temps en stéatite et
durcit au feu percée sur la face opposée
il était fait pour être porter en
pendentif ou à la ceinture leurs
fonctions semble avoir été d'identifier
les personnes à l'origine d'une
transaction commerciale
et a marqué sur un support comme
l'argile ou la cire la propriété des
marchandises malheureusement très petit
support nous sont parvenues le fait que
les sauts ne soit presque présent que
dans les villes d'art à pas et mohenjo
daro t pensez que ces deux villes jouer
un rôle privilégié dans une organisation
administrative mais c'est aussi
peut-être un biais de conservation car
ailleurs déçoit en argile ont été
accidentellement préservé par un feu la
figure animale la plus courante sur les
sauts est appelé la licorne une
représentation stylisée d'un quadrupède
avec une seule corne mélangeant les
caractères de bovins et d'antilopes pour
certains la licorne aurait donc été le
clan dominant de la vallée de l'indus
pour d'autres les animaux sur les sauts
symboliserait des métiers ou des
fonctions sociales et la licorne
pourrait être ainsi le symbole de l'état
mais la clé est sans doute dans les
inscriptions qui leur sont associés
[Musique]
les nombreuses tentatives de
déchiffrement de l'écriture art apn sont
pour l'instant infructueuses et pour de
nombreuses raisons absence d'inscription
bilingue signes abstraits inscriptions
très courte méconnaissance de la langue
qu'elle servait à transcrire et absence
d'écriture postérieur dérivés à tel
point que certains spécialistes comme
steve farmer doute même qu'il s'agisse
d'une écriture mais penche plutôt pour
un système de symbole non linguistique
puisqu'on ne connaît pas de textes longs
de représentation de scribe d'évolution
vers une écriture plus cursive bref tout
ce qu'on connaît ailleurs il s'agit peut
être d'autres choses
plusieurs chercheurs ont affirmé avoir
déchiffré l'écriture a à peine au 20e
siècle mais leurs hypothèses se sont
toujours avérées arbitraire et
impossible à généraliser on attend de
nouvelles trouvailles qui permettront
progresser on sait juste que le texte
devait se lire de droite à gauche car
quand les caractères ne remplissent pas
toutes une ligne il commence toujours à
droite
la disparition des grandes villes au
début du deuxième millénaire avant notre
ère est elle aussi énigmatique mais fou
aux anciennes ont révélé un urbanisme
plus sommaires dans les phase tardive
voire des squatteurs installés dans les
ruines ainsi que des nouveaux motifs de
poterie qui pourrait indiquer l'arrivée
de nouvelles populations
mais cela n'est pas le cas partout pour
expliquer cet effondrement une invasion
de population aryenne de langues
indo-européennes a très souvent été
évoquée
les récits sanskrite du veda garde en
effet la mémoire de ces grandes
migrations aérienne vers le coeur de
l'inde au xvème siècle avant notre ère
mais les nombreuses datation sont
aujourd'hui assez clair afin d' art à
pas vers 1750 avant jésus-christ des
précède de plusieurs siècles et puis
malgré les fantasmes de certains
fouilleurs aucune trace de conflit n'a
été mise en évidence dans les villes
attention donc à ne pas surinterpréter
le rôle des mystérieuses indo européens
comme c'est souvent le cas il faut
partir des vestiges archéologiques et ne
pas chercher à les plier à des
reconstructions linguistique ou des
récits mythiques dans l'état actuel de
nos connaissances on peut penser que les
indo européens n'auraient fait en somme
que combler le vide laissé par apa et
les causes du déclin doit être
recherchée ailleurs les autres
hypothèses pour la fin de la
civilisation de l'indus qui ont été
avancées sont l'épuisement des sols mais
il ya un tel apport d'alluvions fertile
du fleuve que cela paraît difficile en
revanche les maladies comme le paludisme
favorisée par l'inondation de chant
toujours plus étendus a dû être un fléau
assez impitoyable les études de
paléopathologie qui ont été menées sur
les squelettes de mohenjo daro montre
que la malaria était particulièrement
répandu sans doute associé au choléra
l'obsession des arts ap 1 pour l'hygiène
et salles de bains serait peut-être à
comprendre en ce sens comme on l'a dit
en début de vidéo les cours d'eau on
peut aussi changer de lit régulièrement
et les épisodes de sécheresse et
inondations auraient pu fragiliser les
villes la rivière saraswati a par
exemple entièrement disparu au début du
deuxième millénaire alors qu'elle
abritait une très forte densité de sint
habitat notamment la grande
agglomération de gagner rioual à le
changement de lit de la rivière a dû
être une catastrophe fatale mais sans
doute pas à l'échelle de toute la
civilisation alors il ya une autre
possibilité qu'on avait déjà évoqué dans
une vidéo précédente d'ailleurs la
dépendance économique la fin de l'indus
et peut-être à mettre en lien avec le
déclin de nombreuses villes de
mésopotamie du sud au même moment à
cause d'une salinisation des sols qui
fait fortement baisser les rendements
agricoles le pouvoir politique se
déplace vers le nord de la mésopotamie
au deuxième millénaire ce qui a sans
doute distendu les liens avec l'inde us
la perte de ce partenaire commercial
pourrait avoir fragilisé l'économie
européenne l'effondrement graduelle et
passe soudain comme on l'a longtemps
pensé s'étale en réalité entre 2000 et
1700 avant jésus-christ l'époque à
laquelle les sites orientaux comme
gujarat et du gange notamment voient
leur population augmenter plus qu'un
effondrement c'est sans doute un abandon
du coeur du territoire avec un
déplacement dans les marges convoi
s'opérer dans la vallée de l'indus
origines système politique religion
écriture langue peuplement disparition
tout ou presque reste donc largement
mystérieux concernant à rapa et on
espère que les programmes archéologiques
en cours vont nous apporter
d'incroyables nouvelle hypothèse
merci à tous bien sûr il y a plein de
nuances à apporter à cette présentation
rapide alors n'hésitez pas à les trouver
des informations complémentaires jeu
mais comme d'habitude les sources qui
ont servi à préparer la vidéo en bar
d'information et je remercie lucapa cote
à l'écriture et à la documentation chers
abonnés merci encore une fois de votre
soutien vos partages like commentaires
et dont aide véritablement la chaîne
depuis quelques mois il ya vraiment une
transformation qui se passe et qui
permet à la chaîne d'être reconnus et
des projets incroyables qui arrive et
vous n'y est pas pour rien alors avant
le prochain épisode petite surprise je
suis sur france culture du 22 au 26 dans
l'émission sans oser le demander vous ai
préparé des petites chroniques
archéologiques et j'espère que ça vous
plaira vous embrasse je vous remercie et
je vous dis à très vite salut
[Musique]